or berger bonjour bonjour Alors on est
ici à la mairie de Maurepas c'est le 1er
devant rendez-vous vous lancez une
grande participation citoyenne autour
d'un jeu clé ce soir le premier
rendez-vous c'est au tour de la santé et
l'autonomie déjà pourquoi ces deux choix
là déjà parce que je pense que c'est un
sujet essentiel au quotidien
l'inquiétude de pas trouver un médecin
traitant l'angoisse de la perte
d'autonomie alors c'est à la fois la
question de du handicap mais c'est aussi
la perte d'autonomie pour des proches
des personnes plus âgées nos parents et
donc l'idée c'est de parler de ce qui
intéresse le quotidien des gens et
d'essayer de aussi de confronter les
points donc c'est pour ça là on est
juste avant la réunion ne débute elle se
démarrera dans une heure mais l'idée
c'est bien ça de confronter les points
de jeu entre les citoyens des
professionnels de santé des médecins des
sages-femmes des infirmiers qui ont
accepté d'être avec nous et qui vont
pouvoir nous confronter un peu au réel
mais justement pourquoi confronter
toutes ces parties citoyens
professionnels élus ils doivent apporter
chacun leur regard oui parce que en tant
que citoyen on a des demandes on a des
attentes en tant que professionnelle de
santé on en a d'autres en tant on en a
d'autres et puis on doit partager aussi
un niveau de contrainte parfois on
m'envoie des messages en disant moi je
sais ce qu'il faut faire voilà comment
on va sauver le système de santé notre
système à l'hôpital public etc le fait
qu'on partage ensemble à la fois les
attentes réelles les inquiétudes qui
peuvent exister des contraintes et puis
qu'on dégage ensemble des solutions moi
l'engagement que je prends c'est aussi
celui-ci de dire que la partie passion
citoyenne c'est pas juste de réfléchir
ensemble c'est d'essayer de travailler
sur des solutions qu'ensuite moi en tant
que député en tant que présidente de
groupe à l'Assemblée je vais pouvoir
retranscrire dans la loi alors justement
je vous propose de les écouter
et je viens pour essayer de rétablir
certaines contreérités sur les solutions
soi-disant apporter aux problèmes de
pénurie médical à l'heure actuelle en
France qui ne trouveront sûrement pas
leur répondre dans la coercition dans la
quatrième année imposée aux étudiants
ils vont fuir encore plus ils ont raison
je les incite à fuir si c'est comme ça
et sur le toutes les contraintes
administratives qui vont nous être
imposées en plus alors qu'on est en
train d'en mourir et que c'est pour ça
qu'on nous a dégoûté d'exercer un métier
qu'on adore on est en train de
travailler avec le département et
l'Université de Saint-Quentin justement
pour faire que l'internat
en médecine de ville se déploie plus que
aujourd'hui
l'intérêt en fait il est double
renforcer la capacité médicale auprès de
nos médecins de ville qui connaissent
bien qui sont ancrés dans le tissu
communal et puis en espérant que les
étudiants qui sont dans cette commune se
mettent à l'apprécier
vient de prendre sa retraite et que j'ai
beaucoup de mal à prendre rendez-vous
avec un nouveau parce qu'en général il
ne peuvent pas prendre de nouveau
patients
la crise de la covid a renforcé selon un
rapport d'information sénatoriale qui
était rendu en mars 2022 11% des
Français de plus de 17 ans donc pas de
médecin traitant ils sont 600 000 en ALD
affection longue durée nous espérons en
parler avec les participants justement
ce soir de cette ça inquiète de pas
pouvoir prendre rendez-vous parfois bien
sûr le jour J et puis le médecin se sont
urgence bien sûr prétendre bien sûr en
fait ce qui se passe au sein de nos
systèmes d'urgence et le président de la
République a dit se désengorgement qu'on
veut faire en un an de nos systèmes
notre système d'urgence finalement c'est
le thermomètre de tout ce qui
dysfonctionne avant souvent qu'on va aux
urgences on ne va pas pour de bonnes
raisons mais parce qu'on n'a pas d'autre
choix parce qu'on se dit ok je sais que
je devrais pas venir pour ça mais je
sais pas comment faire autrement que
devenir vous voir donc ça met tout le
monde dans un inconfort les
professionnels de santé
c'est ce qu'ils peuvent pas répondre
dans les bons délais aux demandes et
parce qu'ils avaient traités qui
finissent par des plaquer et qu'ils ont
parfois plus de 2000 patients dans
l'équipe évidemment tenir nous
l'engagement qu'on prend c'est de dire
que tous ceux qui sont en affection de
longue durée qui ont des maladies qui
sont extrêmement sévères des maladies
chroniques qui sont vous le savez pris
en charge à 100% dans notre système de
santé notre système de solidarité
retrouve tous d'ici la fin de l'année en
médecine traitant ça c'est l'engagement
très clair qu'on a pris parce qu'on ne
peut pas les laisser sans suivi médical
quelles solutions justement on peut
mettre en place pour ceci on va manquer
de médecins le numéro de clausus a
longtemps freiner les entrées il y a une
année supplémentaire pour les médecins
généralistes ils ont une quatrième année
est-ce que ça part tarder il faudrait
presque 10 ans au contraire on est le
résultat alors il y a plusieurs choses
qu'on a fait déjà le numéro de clausus
c'est fini et donc ça veut dire que
cette espèce de vieille
mais est-ce que les places en internat
sont ouvertes alors
elles sont très largement ouvertes mais
le numéro de ce que je a été créé à un
moment où on que moins de médecins ça
ferait moins de dépenses de santé mais
en fait ça marche pas comme ça c'est à
dire qu'à un moment les maladies elles
ont aussi évoluées il y a eu plus de
maladies chroniques donc on a eu plus de
demandes donc le numéro exclusus on a
fait sauter ce verrou qui objectivement
n'avait aucun sens et c'était nécessaire
de pouvoir le faire on a fait monter
aussi en compétence d'autres professions
médicales qui ont moins d'années de
formation et qui peuvent non pas
remplacer le médecin c'est pas ça et qui
peuvent réaliser un certain nombre
d'actes vous parlez d'un parcours de
soins presque c'est ça je pense par
exemple à nos sages-femmes on le voit
bien en tant que femme la difficulté de
trouver un gynécologue et bien on a la
quasi-totalité de nos actes à part
sûrement où ça n'est pas grave le suivi
au quotidien y compris le suivi d'une
grossesse qui peut être réalisée par la
sage-femme et donc on les a fait monter
en compétences de manière elle se soit
beaucoup plus autonome dans leurs actes
le pharmacien c'est un très bon exemple
avant le covid on pouvait pas se faire
vacciner chez son pharmacien aujourd'hui
ça paraît presque anodin mais non ça
n'était pas ça n'était pas possible on a
fait là aussi sauter
on pouvait pas se faire vexer maintenant
qu'est-ce qui se passe on va acheter son
vaccin et en fait on va se faire
vacciner immédiatement ce qui évite de
perdre des doses ce qui évite pour
l'Assurance Maladie de perdre de
l'argent et ce qui est surtout beaucoup
plus efficace pour tout le monde il y a
aussi les questions de l'autonomie on
l'a dit oui tout à l'heure c'est un
sujet là aussi primordial en 2030 le nom
de personnes en perte d'autonomie en
France atteindra 1,6 millions c'est 2,5
en 2060 quel serait les solutions pour
permettre aux gens de ne pas perdre de
tenue parce que c'est chez eux on sait
que les épanouies pour réputation
actuellement beaucoup de personnes âgées
veulent finir leur vie chez elle est-ce
que déjà vous avez des pistes est-ce que
vous espérez ce soir trouver des pistes
aussi c'est l'objectif en tout cas
évidemment de ce genre de réunion et qui
est un lieu d'échange vous voyez bien me
la configuration l'idée c'est pas moi
qui parle oui c'est moi le travail
justement et confronté encore une fois
les points de vue après sur l'autonomie
déjà on est en train d'examiner une loi
une proposition de loi d'initiative de
mon groupe justement sur ce sujet parce
qu'on est passé en procédure accélérée
le 11 avril dernier on a n'a pas pu
finir mais on va finir dans quelques
semaines son examen et c'est une loi
importante notamment sur la lutte contre
la maltraitance en EHPAD il faut aussi
envoyer un message clair là-dessus parce
que oui il y a eu des scandales mais moi
je suis au quotidien j'échange avec
celles et ceux qui travaillent en épagne
plus on est en train de dire de dégrader
aussi l'image des EHPAD moins évidemment
je serai de vocation de gens qui auront
envie de travailler parce que ce qu'ils
m'ont dit ça m'avait beaucoup frappé
quand j'étais allé les visiter c'était
pas vous rendre compte donc pendant la
crise covid on nous applaudissez au
balcon et là maintenant nous insulte
donc on passe d'un extrême à l'autre il
y a comme partout malheureusement des
gens qui font mal leur travail mais qui
sont très minoritaires et leur
évidemment quand ça tombe sur quelqu'un
qui est de votre famille c'est
absolument insupportable c'est un digne
et ça doit être sanctionné et très
durement sanctionné mais la vérité c'est
que ce sont souvent des gens qui sont
passionnés par leur métier qui sont dans
des métiers pénibles dans des métiers
difficiles aussi il faut former plus
évidemment il faut former plus mais il
faut aussi donner envie que ces métiers
soient exercés donc il faut essayer de
très vigilant sur l'image qu'on renvoie
de ces métiers et puis après la de
est-ce que on souhaite aller dans un
lieu qui a un lieu aussi collectif
médicalisé parfois on n'a pas d'autre
choix parce qu'en fonction des
pathologies notamment neurodégénératives
quand vous êtes par exemple atteint
d'Alzheimer de manière très
significative vous avez des risques qui
sont importants et donc vous avez besoin
d'être dans un espace qui est aussi
sécurisé on le voit pour de risques que
des personnes par exemple je suis vieux
et ne savent pas en fait plus qu'elles
sont non plus leurs repères etc donc
c'est aussi pour le bien des personnes
parfois et c'est souvent très douloureux
pour les familles elles-mêmes il faut en
faire ce choix de la médicalisation mais
quand on peut adapter le logement alors
on doit le faire ça c'est ce qu'on veut
faire c'est l'engagement qu'on a pris et
ce qu'on appelle ma prime adapt m'a
appris ma date c'est de faire en sorte
que l'État vienne vous soutenir dans
toutes les rénovations que vous avez à
faire dernière question est-ce qu’un
compte-rendu sera fait les propositions
seront montrées à remonter à François
Brown le ministre de la Santé au
président Emmanuel Macron alors moi
l'engagement que je prends c'est ça
c'est à dire c'est pas juste un lieu
d'échange et de débat c'est d'abord ça
c'est utile de se reparler on voit bien
que dans le contexte parfois il y a de
la tension et c'est pas toujours facile
de se parler mais je pense que c'est
nécessaire qu'on aille au devant sur des
sujets qui sont des sujets de
préoccupation première des Français mais
oui c'est que les propositions qui
ressortiront de ces rendez-vous de ces
échanges avec les professionnels moi
évidemment je les remettrai au ministre
et puis si je peux moi-même les
retranscrire parce que c'est aussi notre
initiative du parlementaire évidemment
je le ferai vous avez déjà une date pour
rendre ce compte rendu il faut déjà
qu'on travaille ce soir et après
évidemment avant l'été je souhaite que
les propositions au moins sur ce premier
thème je puisse être bien précisé
échanger après avec les professionnels
de santé de manière à ce qu'elle puisse
être remise merci Aurore berger de nous
avoir demandé cet entretien